everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the kiziditsky
gambit in
the king's gambit accepted line i want
to thank our sponsor today from
skillshare more from them later in the
video so the king's gambit my favorite
opening in all of chess starts out with
e4
e5
f4 and then in the accepted line pawn
takes on f4 and then knight f3 black has
a lot of different options they can
attack us from but we're going to be
looking at the move g5 g5 is usually met
by h4 this is the most common way
and after pawn pushes to g4
this is where the game that we're going
to be looking at today gets into and
that is when the knight comes to e5
white also has the option of playing g5
but i think the e5 variation is much
stronger now the four
lines that we're going to look at from
black standpoint the first one is knight
to f6 then we're also going to look at
d6 more of that fischer attack just
playing d6 opening up for the light
squared bishop here we're also going to
look at h5 protecting this g4 pawn
that's now being attacked by the knight
on e5 and then lastly we're going to
look at bishop to
g7
the first ration we're going to look at
is if they play knight 2 f6 one theme to
always be
thinking about when you play this is
when the knight's on e5 we're attacking
the f7 square which is the weakest
square for black early on because the
king is the only piece that is defending
it so if they're not going to attack our
knight on e5
we're gonna be looking to play bishop c4
getting more material into the game
attacking critical squares right now f7
is our target so the bishop and the
knight are both attacking this square
now the most common move that they're
going to play is d5 but they may not
play this and so in these openings it's
always good to understand what the
approach is so that if they don't play
the normal moves which we'll go over d5
as well that you understand what you're
getting after so let's say they play
knight to c6 okay well in this case
we're gonna take with our bishop on f7
a lot of the king's gambit especially in
the accepted lines
is to get a very very strong attack they
can't take our bishop it's protected by
the knight here so we're going to force
them to e7 this is a terrible square for
the king you can see it's blocking both
the queen and the bishop from coming to
the central squares
but you can also see from here the
knights attacking our knights now we
could just bring our bishop back uh but
i really like the move pawn
d four this is better than i think
bishop to b3 because then they're going
to take right here we push up on
d4
they can move their knight away we can
start to push a little bit forward but i
don't think that's nearly as good as
just pushing up to d4 now if they were
to take i think it's really a
mistake here because let's say they take
with their knights then we're just going
to take with their pawn
they're probably going to take our
bishop now so they take with their king
we take it with their pawn but then they
take with their queen and we can take
with our bishop now if you look at this
and say why why the bishop can't they
just take our bishop well no they really
can't because if they take with their
queen then we can play rook to f1 and we
are pinning down their queen to the king
so that would be a huge blunder they
would lose their queen i always like to
put my opponent in a position where they
can make a lot of mistakes so
yes we can actually take this pawn back
and then if you look at the material
here
both sides are
even as far as the pawns but you can see
that the king is completely exposed and
we have a lot of strong attackers and we
can even bring our rook here to f1 we
can potentially castle on
the queen side but maybe they don't take
our queen or our bishop on f4 and they
decide oh let's go ahead and blow up the
queen side and they attack on b2
well we have some pretty strong attacks
here
first with queen to d5 i think queen
taking on b2 would be a huge mistake for
them queen 2 d5 gets us on the attack
here
king comes back to e8 we can castle on
the king side here and they have a
couple options if they were to play c6
attacking our queen we'll kind of go
through the threats here
queen 2 h5 check you can see this would
be a disaster king 2 d8 now we play
bishop e5 we're attacking the queen and
the rook up here maybe queen 2 c2
gobbling up some material but then we
can play bishop to
uh f6 check they move their king we now
get our knight involved into the game we
have so many threats on the board uh b6
now we take their their rook here so uh
lots of ways for them to mess this up if
they decide instead okay c6 doesn't do a
lot well let's get our queen involved
into the action queen to b6 i think is
better after they take on b2 this is
czech so we're gonna have to play king
h1 but then how do they really stop
things one move is queen two c5 say okay
yeah if you're going to be attacking i
need to control this
fifth rank right here
because we already saw that bad stuff
happens if you play queen's h5 but now
this is another spot where we can put
this in a tough position we can play the
move bishop takes c7
another pawn that we can catch with our
bishop and we're just baiting them to
say go ahead and take our bishop it's a
freeze piece go ahead and take it now
this would be a huge mistake because if
they do take it now we have the move
queen to f7
you can see after the king moves then we
can play queen to f6 check and then
after the king comes back we can take
their rook on h8
so let's come back to the beginning
after bishop to c4 that was if they
played knight to c6 and just really
ignore the f7 square the most common
play that they're going to make is d5
this opens up for their light square
bishop to get involved into the action
it blocks the bishop right away and also
opens up for their queen to defend this
d5 square
as well when they do that we're going to
go and take with our pawn that's pretty
much always going to happen
and then they're usually going to play
d6 now if they don't play d6 i think it
is a big mistake for them but
getting this bishop
attacking this knight is critical as
well as just opening up for black to
castle on the king's side if they want
to i think is the best approach and also
stopping this pawn from pushing forward
from blockading this pawn it also stops
the threat of the light square bishop
attacking the f7 square a lot of things
that black really needs to do
in this opening once they do that we're
going to be playing pawn to
d4
now i do think if they castle on the
king side it's a mistake because we can
just take here on
f4 so instead i think they probably need
to play knight to h5 this is defending
the f4 square not the easiest move to
always find
bring your knight to
the h file not super common but if they
do that i think now castle on the king
side adding another attacker on the f4
square
now if they get pretty aggressive they
could play queen takes on h4
and this is if i'm playing black this is
the path i like to play because i think
it's very aggressive and it's very
difficult for white to get the upper
hand but in this case i think white
needs to be playing queen to e1 and just
try to stop the attack from black now
it's not easy for black by any means
white still has the two central pawns
even though there are double pawns on
the d-file black has no central
pawns
the king is completely exposed even if
the castle on the king's side it's not a
very safe king as well
and so there is a blockade in the middle
with the knight on e5 so white still has
a very very strong game by no means
is black able to take advantage of this
but white does not have the upper hand
as far as the attack so just keep that
in mind that's what's going to happen
early on if they play knight to
f6 and then we bring our bishop to c4
now a word from our sponsor skillshare
if you're not familiar with skillshare
it's an online community where you can
take classes on pretty much anything
that you want i just got through going
through mkbhd's
youtube success class
really good content i'm just interested
personally in other big channels and how
they approach youtube how they get
engagement and have high quality content
so if you're interested in skillshare
what's nice is they're giving the first
thousand people to click the link below
in the description as well as the pinned
comments
a free month so if you haven't checked
it out definitely click below and let me
know what you think
coming back to the next variation is if
black plays d6 i always like to also
give my recommendation if you are facing
this
if i'm playing black i do like the d6
variation the most i just think it
really puts white on the defensive more
than some of the other options in this
case d6 reminder that if they're not
attacking our knights we're usually
going to bring our bishop to c4
if they are attacking our knight we're
going to need to come back now in this
case
because they're attacking our knights
and this pawn on g4 is not under attack
we're going to go ahead and bring our
knight back to g4 and capture this
material right here
the problem is is they have a very
strong move with bishop to e7
now the queen and the bishop are both
attacking this pawn
at some point we're going to need to
come back to f2 it doesn't really matter
if we do it on this next move or in two
moves because it's either going to be d4
and then knight to f2 or knight to f2
and then d4 because
the reason they play e7 is because
they're going to capture on at the next
square we're going to need to come to f2
at this point and stop it and so that's
why you know it doesn't really matter if
you play uh
after bishop to e7 you could play pawn
to d4 first and then bishop and then the
knight comes back here that's fine
or you could just play after
the bishop
you could play knight to f2 and then
bishop to h4 and then d4 they're the
exact same thing but usually i like to
just start with d4 okay so bishop takes
h4
knight to f2
and then the bishop to
g3 now the reason this is important is
because they also they want to keep the
pressure pinning down the knights to the
king but they also want to make sure
that we can't just take bishop on f4
once we do that we've really started to
get a good structure on the king side of
the board but the bishop on g3 stops
that okay so we need to get other
material involved into the game
especially adding more pressure on the
f4 square we're going to start by
playing queen f3 now we have both our
bishop on c1 and our queen attacking the
pawn now if they continue to add
pressure remember they don't have to
play the optimal moves i'm kind of going
over the best moves that they play and
trying to teach you the the themes that
you should be looking out for but if
they don't want to hold on to the f4
square then we're just going to take
with our bishop that's completely fine
but if they try to maintain it which
they should try maybe queen to g5
then we can just develop more material
knight to c3 maybe they play knight to
c6 developing but now we can play knight
e2 this does two things one it still
defends this square on d4 which is under
attack but now it also attacks the
bishop on
g3 remember they blew up our king side
of the board anytime that h pawn goes
away
the king is pretty vulnerable on the
king side now we can castle on the queen
side if we ever wanted to more than
likely we're just going to stay in the
center of the board but you can see once
we start to blow up attack this bishop
they really don't have a strong attack
that they can do much else with so
that's what's going to happen if they
play bishop to e7 early on more than
likely they're going to be coming to h4
and that's how you should respond
against that
so if we come back the next variation
we're going to be looking at is instead
of d6 if they play the move h5
hopefully you're following along with
the theme of if our knights not under
attack on e5 we're going to be playing
bishop c4
bishop and knight both attacking the
pawn on f7 now they need to hold down
this pawn on the previous version when
we looked at this position the knight
was actually here on f6 so the best move
and really the only good square that
black has to go to is knight to h6 this
is developing the knight although not
the greatest square but it is defending
the square here on f7 they don't just
want to play you know d5 then we just
take with our bishop we still have the
same threat but then we just got a a
free pawn here so the best move for them
is knight to h6 in this case we're going
to be playing pawn to d4 opening up
defending this e5 knights we have two
central pawns we're also opening up for
the dark square bishop to come to
f4
so in this spot if we look at it okay
where would they go from there uh the
first one is let's say bishop to e7 now
we earlier looked at the threat of the
bishop coming to e7 how dangerous that
was because the queen
and the bishop on e7 both attacking on
h4 but now we can still just take on f4
and if they take with their bishop
before we were kind of stuck we had to
bring our knight to f2 but now we can
play g3 because the bishop on f4 is
protecting it so we're not really
worried about bishop to e7 that would be
a pretty bad move now the other option
is d6
so delaying the d6 move till after they
play h5 and knight to h6 here opens up
for the light square bishop to get
involved into the game and now it's
attacking the knights and the knights
usually when it's attacked by d6 it
comes back to g4 it can't do that now
because that's being protected by the
pawn and the knight so this knight does
need to come back to d3 but this is a
tough spot the knight and the bishop are
attacking this pawn on f4
this bishop on c4 is still attacking
this f7 square that is yes defended by
the ninth but you don't just want to
leave your knight on h6 the entire time
so finding the best way for black to
continue is difficult you know if you
try to just push forward on f3 okay well
you could just take here
and take i think is extremely bad
because now you take with your queen on
f3 and now you're attacking with your
queen and your bishop and now you're
really putting a lot of pressure on your
opponent to just stay here with knight
on h6 but if instead if they don't take
well what if they just play bishop to e7
but now we can just again take on bishop
f4 and we've completely controlled the
center of the board and now it's even
easier if we want to to castle on the
queen side
and now how does black really continue i
think this is a good spot for for white
the last variation we're going to look
at is if they play bishop to
g7 now reminder if they're not attacking
our knight we're playing bishop to c4 if
they are attacking our knight we need to
figure out how we're going to respond
now we have a couple options we can go
ahead and take on g4 but i like the
approach of playing
d4
d4 allows us to control the center of
the board we're not under any immediate
threat right now especially not from a
pawn if they attack us with a pawn we
obviously have to move but pawn to d4
opens up we can now play bishop takes on
f4 we can get our light square bishop
bald into the game so i think this is
the best approach now if they play d6 we
have to look at things a little bit
differently before we could always play
knight takes on g4 which we're still
going to do here but they really
wouldn't capture with their bishop
because then we would just take their
bishop and that's not really the best
exchange because typically this tends to
be an open board state meaning there's
usually not a lot of pawns in the center
of the board towards the end game and
bishops are better than knights in that
position just because they can control
more of the board
but in this position it's a little bit
different because once the queen comes
to g4 then black can actually take the
pawn on d4 so it is slightly different
in the exchange on why they may actually
decide to go ahead and take with their
bishop on at g4 but that's completely
okay because now we can just take their
pawn
on f4
and then both sides are
equal in material both sides have six
pawns neither side is feeling great
about their position but white does have
the bishop pair and i think going to the
end game they have a better setup maybe
they play knight to c6 getting material
involved into the game we can do the
same now if they want to exchange i
think that's fine yes we have the double
pawns on the c file which is not great
for us but now they have no bishops we
have the bishop here i think going to
the end game this would be good for us i
don't necessarily see them giving up
their only bishop but they definitely
could if they don't that's fine as well
we can get our star score bishop
involved into the game we could even
castle on the queen side depending on
how they continue uh but all in all this
is how i would approach it so those are
the four most common variations that you
will run into
but thank you guys so much for watching
the video thank you to our sponsor
skillshare remember link in the
description below if you'd like to sign
up for a free month first thousand
people to click on that and sign up
we'll get a free month thanks again to
them
if you have another video recommendation
please let me know in the comments below
i'll definitely be looking at those to
see what you guys want to see in the
future but thanks for watching i'll see
you in the next video
you